all right Tyrone welcome to the channel
oh hey it's Gregory over here this is
Tyrone Magnus he's new to YouTube Tyrone
what we're gonna do is a reaction video
what's that that I mean it sounds silly
it sounds ridiculous like who the hell's
really gonna watch this Tyrone this is
where our friend right here is gonna
watch us watching a video and then we'll
talk about it afterwards
oh yeah just be really into the video
you know I feel like people don't like
it when you talk over when people are
talking in the video be invested and you
may be yourself be yourself I feel like
you need advice on how to be comfortable
in front of the camera yeah I'm here for
you Tyra okay cool
I'm just gonna take this chance to plug
myself I just started my youtube channel
Tyrone Magnus and you can go over there
but I've it support me haha hey I'm just
doing here to get to get the word out
who I am let's see that yes anywhere
ever giving me a chance to do this not a
not a problem
I don't know I feel like you kind of
need someone like me in order okay
whatever
so we're gonna start with 65 year-old
man marries twelve-year-old girl child
marriage social experiment I hope this
is exactly what it sounds like it's
rigged I wanted to know what it wolf
thing oh do you think like it's not a
real right just Baroness oh [ __ ] what's
up guys I'm Colby person I recently saw
a video online of how child marriage is
legal and more than
91 countries in the world children as
young as six years old are forced to
marry older men and have their childhood
stripped away from them well it's legal
the United States for children to get
married well it turns out it is in some
states it can be as low as 12 years old
so we wanted to do with photos no see
how the public would react to an older
man marrying a younger child Oh God
seal out of emotions sure
d/f calm there we go we're thinking
there she got loose he's looking unhappy
salivating sneeze selling man what at
this Lord she look happy
he's that we God ways this in a place
that's not leaking this is at that time
square times
okay
if I think in Finnish Wow anciently is
not a square oh dude follow the idea
grats I'm just great since then this is
good yes
the gravity version from the current
okay when you have it
experiment nice you wonder right
is it good I'd be that guy is like you
know we don't know their side of the
story
they gave me yes you look good with your
bad girl
girl custody now they talking about the
classroom no not the 12 year I'll be
over the [ __ ] thing okay that's nice
too good a girl some of these things
it's a pretty video word experiment yeah
is this an experiment video this a real
[ __ ]
waters permission parrots permission yes
oh he's idiot no no this is like you
three
really that's a lot of girls that's a
lot of [ __ ] women
well I couldn't help kind of find that a
little funny at the same time because I
knew it was fake yeah cuz it was an
experiment but it made me wonder just
you know I just been such a lot of
channels that or a few channels that
have got caught you know doing fake
pranks you know sometimes I see stuff
like that you know as actors you can you
can tell when people are acting but
maybe like you say those guys were a
little too good
were you talking about the young guys
that were coming at him oh no I was
talking about the actual guy man I
thought you were talking about the young
guys were like yo yeah it was just
something about that was I say you think
I might have been fit well I mean it
could be fake if the facts though are
just that correct to like thirty three
thousand girls a day yeah that's low man
that it's easily calculates over to a
million women in here if people still
wouldn't be comfortable with it I do
know that people saying that done in
public she really sold it though such a
significant yeah she was like way
depressed and I couldn't help but by to
kind of find when she was asked to do
this was this to send a message or we
need you to be a really good actress cuz
we're gonna pull a joke on a lot of
people right yeah just need to sit there
and what's sad hold on okay I can do
that
I couldn't tell this was an experiment
or a prank it I just yeah both cuz I
think they do pranks too damn dude we
need like being Neeson to get in there
start kicking some ass holy [ __ ] hello
funny if you walked up in her away don't
take this serious truth is dead yeah
that stuff does happening I've heard of
it
you know people told me about it and but
what if they okay just what if all right
right but what if the 12 year old girl
happened to be the one who was like no I
really um enforced this decision
remember when Dakota Fanning came out on
the screen a big part of her personality
was she was 12 but she's so behaved but
she was 25 years old and that was like a
consistent in her personality what if
like a twelve-year-old girl was like a
Dakota Fanning type of twelve-year-old
girl and she was really insistent and
the guy felt pressured into marrying her
when he didn't want to know hence
Hakkasan why do you think he's working
so hard to get a hundred thousand
subscribers I heard he just got it
congratulations that allows him to get
out of his contract with the 12-year
that's the only I've heard that in
certain Asian countries it's like just
natural that a lot older men marry
younger women like it's just a thing
though why not arrange although it may
be when you say younger do you mean like
like 12 year 12 years old no I mean like
it might be an established 50 year old
man it's routine for a lot of them to
marry 20 year old women okay in that
culture
young women look to older men to marry
it's just a thing I say that's what I've
heard
well it's true but that's what I've
heard even over here though it's funny
I've been approached about girls they're
like you're 18 you do realize that I'm
39 years old yeah you don't look 39
times I like older men okay all righty
you know know so I mean like it happens
they're sometimes they do go after the
mid you don't look 39 I don't I thought
you were 28 when I heard like yeah you
know that's how did you know that okay
cuz they watch cyclops
watch my channel always establish your
age on all your videos you do it I'm CC
five videos a week now but I'm saying I
was told
like I'm like girly no coming after me
you know you know 39 yeah I know
got your gay gay you know you don't care
out no I've even had girls was funny
that was dating that were older that
were like you know in their late 20s or
are in their 30s and they said to me
know what we'll each do you get that set
up set up even had 18 19 20 year olds
they actually are insecure about that
they're like did good name would become
worried that younger girls gonna come
and take me away from them and we were
coming fishel I thought that that was
interesting I wouldn't have thought that
they would be bothered by that you know
I don't know it's just that this
interesting thought I'm still stuck on
the thought of Pakistan and a 12 year
old girl well I will ask a wicked ass
caucus all about though Congrats by the
way on hydrogen I ain't no here 200k
that's my way of saying congratulations
he's probably gonna marry who's a
underage asian girl front to his head on
his channel well might be legal in Japan
have you heard his girlfriend was his
girlfriend his girlfriend his asian girl
he has an actual girl yes he does we
should be like she's been on his his
channel okay
migoo is she not Game of Thrones I
haven't seen her we have miles are
Monica maybe you're honest but she have
you ever heard end time
were I haven't seen it in the past yes I
have well she in certain episodes sounds
just like them
okay like something scary will happen on
the screen here ago see sounds just like
the fat tie or you're an asian porn well
she sounds like I'm like oh they don't
always make that sound when you're
having sex they make that sound when
they're scared too but here's a lot of
raping like forced upon porn in asian
porn and cookies yeah i mean so like
girls are always scared and like I don't
like watching it I'm just saying I know
cuz I've seen it I was actually with a
girl it was in it at night I'd to tell
her to stop I feel like I was taking
yeah okay
well ah Kisan here's your congratulatory
video to you and your girlfriend
delicious no no but if you're new to the
real rejects subscribe today
Tyron just launched the channel who
knows what's gonna be on the channel one
is what kind of videos will be primarily
consist of who knows
check it out wait to get notified might
be a few months from now when you find
out about his channel right I could blow
up in those a gaming channel I remind
you of [ __ ] story that that's right
Twitter Facebook get damned if you're
actually doing the social media work
yeah stuff it takes to be successful in
the entertainment industry promote
yourself on all the platforms gee a
snapchat I do
Tyrone man I do snapshot T Magnus with
3s you're gonna get a role in a movie
where you play Hitler's eldest brother
pourcel son